what what what is he laughing about
Carville what is he laughing about Trump
literally said I'm not talking about
those people he that's what he actually
said one other guy who I can who I'm so
proud to call a friend and a colleague
through what we do at Rumble uh is Dan
banino Dan banino is on the Trump side
of this thing I am on the disantis side
of this thing but Dan is calling balls
and Strikes the way I am and he saw me
on uh on Real Time call out this
nonsense with James Carville and he gave
me a little credit and I think it's
worth so I'm playing this not to Pat
myself on the back I'm pay I'm playing
this to give banino a little credit cuz
we are on opposite sides of this thing
but we're both fighting for truth and
for America and I think that's important
to note Carville was on Bill Maher this
weekend with a friend of mine Dave Rubin
who did a good job by the way and I
credit him he's a disantis guy but he's
my friend and a good friend and he did
the right thing he could have knocked
Trump on this Charlottesville thing and
Dave didn't and this is the kind of
stuff I credit people with even when we
don't support the same guy he's a good
man okay he can you know he can fight
for his guy here's Carville this is a
sign here they are ready to go full
Charlottesville on Trump even though
that good people thing is a total
hoax check this out the kids seem to be
with the
Palestinians and the older generation
seems to be with Israel well the kids
are with tick tock with whatever Tik Tok
tell them to be for basically well that
is where a lot of what would a good
people on both sides of
Charlottesville I don't know did I hear
that or did I make that up that Trump
said they're good people on both sides
he he didn't say that he did not he he
well he said it but a sentence later he
said I'm not talking about the white
supremacists and and the Neo-Nazi
yeah it's
like what what what is he laughing about
Carville what is he laughing about Trump
literally said I'm not talking about
those people he that's what he actually
said folks Carville said this is not an
accident okay although that may not have
been an intended part of his little
monologue there whatever the hell he was
doing on Bill Mars show it's now clear
to me that now that the Biden record is
totally not savable and that Magics is
starting to Trend no I'm not kidding I
didn't make that up don't credit me with
it aonics people are starting to go back
go wait where's my wallet wait it was a
lot thicker in the Trump years holy
I'm losing money with Biden now that
maganic is starting to Trend that people
are starting to go all right whatever
you don't like his personality you don't
like this he's too much of a queen's guy
a New York guy Trump yeah I don't really
care I want my business to succeed the
Biden team's freaking out so how do you
get people to hate him you got to go
full
Charlottesville You Gotta Go full
Charlottesville and again even though as
Dan just said we happen to be on
different sides in in this primary the
side that Dan and I are on are is the
side of truth it's the side of America
so I have no problem uniting with Dan
Bonino against the forces that will lie
relentlessly against James Carville who
at this point like either James Carville
is a he's a complete liar like he's just
like a Democrat hack or he's an idiot
who shouldn't be on television now I I
say that meaning I spent some time in
the green room with the guy right
beforehand he wasn't mean we had a nice
little chat for a moment and as I said
to you yesterday the next time I go on
the show I'm not going to sit in the
green room with the other guest because
once you become friendly for a moment
with somebody it's hard 10 minutes
before to be kind of laughing with
somebody or how your kids or tell me
about your life and then they say
something idiotic on the show and you
kind of want to pull the punches so you
could see the way I softly I didn't jump
on him I said well actually here's what
happened but either Carville has he's
either a complete liar which he's a he's
a Democrat campaign uh spokesman so you
know in essence he probably is a
complete LI or he's an idiot but either
way I don't see how you could put
someone like that on television anymore
anyway Dan you watching this if you
don't see I toy anyone else that
believes in truth and freedom in America
and wants to get out of this nonsense
and not call all of the people who are
actually generally Standing Up Against
Racism racist and everything else we got
to figure out a way out of
this